hace poco llegó a mi casa y viene
corriendo hacia mí mi hijo de 4 años
vestido de astronauta y me dice mami
entre todos tus viajes
no ha sido en la luna
y me quedé pensando en que precisó un
momento creíste que imposible lograr lo
que otros han hecho realidad tomó su
casco de astronauta y muy emocionado me
pidió que lo llevara al parque ese día
venía yo muy cansada de trabajo pero qué
bueno que acepte ir porque ese día iba a
prender tres grandes lecciones que hoy
quiero compartir con ustedes caminamos y
de pronto me dice mamá ya viste la luna
y si era una luna ese tipo de luna al
que no le puedes quitar la vista de
encima
espectacular espléndida auténtica yo
pienso que así debería de ser todo lo
que hagamos en nuestra vida tu producto
tu servicio
tu empresa tu equipo de trabajo pero
sobre todo tu liderazgo tiene que ser
tan único tan auténtico tan espectacular
que la gente cuando esté en contacto
contigo contigo y contigo exclamen como
wang cuando vemos este tipo de lunes en
la noche
wow con esa persona
caminamos un poco más para llegar al
parque y de pronto me hice mamá no lo
vas a creer otra luna yo no mi amor es
la misma luna no mamá son dos lunas
distintas dimos una vuelta más y ya que
llegamos al parque me dicen mamá
tres lunas
yo he tenido la oportunidad de trabajar
con muchos líderes alrededor del mundo
creando los consultando los guiándolos
asesorando los he aprendido de liderazgo
gracias a ellos pero también he
aprendido de liderazgo gracias a los
libros al aprendizaje de mi día a día a
mis experiencias pero ese día ese día me
había dado cuenta lo maravilloso que se
siente ser sorprendido por un líder que
es capaz de ver cosas nuevas y mágicas
donde otros siempre vemos lo mismo
como cuando eras niño que no importaba
cuántas veces vieras la misma película
porque siempre la ibas a ver con los
ojos de la primera vez y te aprendían
los diálogos y el nombre de los
personajes y la canción y quizá la veías
una y otra vez para entender para
aprender y si no entendías cuando eras
niño preguntabas porque todos vivimos
ese periodo en donde todo era un por qué
por qué por qué por qué tantas que tu
mamá y tu papá se volvieron expertos en
que en responder pues porque si ya deja
de preguntar
hoy me sorprende mucho ver cómo hay
líderes en las empresas y cómo hay
personas en el mundo que van como
dormidos como encajonados como como si
fueran siempre viendo y creyendo lo
mismo y ya nada le sorprende sin prestar
atención focalizada ni a las personas ni
a las cosas
para ser un buen líder y estar en el
spotlight de una organización tienes que
convertirte en un experto en resolver
problemas y entender que para eso te
pagan para resolver problemas y decirle
venga hecha de los problemas no hay
problema yo lo resuelvo no es mi culpa
pero si es mi oportunidad y volverte
altamente creativo y hacer que las cosas
sucedan en lo personal eso a mí me ha
salvado en mi vida me dices no y yo veo
como si me dices no lo vas a lograr y yo
veo la forma de lograrlo me dices es
imposible y yo intentaré hacer lo
posible la primera lección que había
aprendido ese día es ver cosas nuevas y
mágicas donde otros ven siempre lo mismo
es posible sí sí es posible
mamá jugamos a ver quién gana de aquí al
árbol que está allá y ahí tienen al
pequeño astronauta corriendo y yo con
tacones como asistente atrás de él y de
pronto veo que se cae
llena de tierra toda su ropa un agujero
en el pantalón yo ya veía ambulancia
tarjetas de crédito transfusión de
sangre rehabilitación llegó me acerco y
le digo mi amor estás bien se para se
sacude y me dice no me dolió mamá
y claro cuando fuiste niño y aprendiste
a caminar te caíste un promedio de 17
veces por hora
y nunca te cuestionas te hay no caminos
para mí mejor me dedico a otras cosas
y cuanto sea la primera caída es tan no
lo voy a lograr me van a rechazar ese
proyecto no me van a aceptar no voy a
poder emprender no es lo mío me da miedo
equivocarse pues equivocas te
equivocaste conscientemente 12 17 veces
pero descubre reinvéntate explora
experimenta y si te caes levántate
levántate levántate todas las veces y
sacude te vi no me dolió porque cuando
eras niño te equivocas si no tuviste
miedo a equivocarte y cuando eras niño
no te tomabas la vida tan en serio es
más muchos de ustedes bailaron frente a
un espejo por la simple emoción de verse
bailar
y quería ser pintor arquitecto bailarina
y nada ni nadie podía anteponerse a tus
grandes sueños porque ya eras un gran
líder y confiados en ti y en tus
talentos
y que con los niños lo vemos cada día es
un día nuevo para empezar desde cero con
una página en blanco y no importa el
pasado porque cada niño se levanta todos
los días diciendo hoy voy a escribir mi
historia con una nueva página en blanco
con nuevas oportunidades
yo también he caído muchas veces en mi
vida unas más dolorosas que otras
y cuando te caes cuando te caes piensas
bueno literalmente pero cuando te caes
piensas que cada día es un nuevo día
para comenzar de cero ya mí esa
practicidad de mente me ha ayudado mucho
así que cada rechazo cada no es una
nueva oportunidad para hacerlo mejor y
esa había sido mi segunda gran lección
levántate siempre y di no me dolió es
posible sí sí es posible
y de pronto veo a mi hijo con esa mágica
conexión que tienen los niños cuando
juegan con nuestro niño que no conocen
porque cuando eras niño no importaba el
origen ni la nacionalidad ni el tono de
piel de tus amigos ni que estudiaban y
qué hacían sus papás porque sabías de la
importancia de encontrar los puntos de
conexión más que de los de
distanciamiento y valora vas a las
personas por su esencia y no importaba
si con tu amigo hablaba otro idioma
porque tú como buen líder y vas a saber
darte entender
y que muchas veces tener mixtas t con un
amigo pero tus ganas de jugar eran
siempre más grandes y fuertes
porque se valoraba en tu grupo de amigos
tu esencia tu autenticidad o espíritu de
buena voluntad y sobre todo porque
sabías perfectamente que un castillo de
arena en el mar se construye mejor entre
dos
y sabías que para lograr estos puntos de
conexión tenías que sonreír un niño
sonríe alrededor de 300 veces al día los
adultos apenas lo hacemos 25 y hay
algunos que lo hacen punto 5 el casi
casi sale si le dices cuánto te debo
perdón cuánto te debo por tu sonrisa
la sonrisa abre los canales de
comunicación y según la neurociencia
para que me crean
si tú sonríes eres percibido como más
competente y capaz y sobre todo como más
atractivo y bello ya todos están
sonriendo
y sabías que para lograr esos puntos de
conexión cuando eras niño lo habías
hecho muy bien en tu día si habías dado
las gracias y habías pedido perdón
viendo a los ojos y con la mano en el
corazón
hoy esa ha sido la llave mágica en mi
vida ver a la gente regalarle el
contacto viéndolo a los ojos sonriendo
los y haciéndote brillar gracias a ellos
la gente está ávida de eso de ese
reconocimiento
ser una mamá que trabaja que viaja me
permite valorar mucho más el tiempo que
estoy con mi familia así como me permite
valorar también mucho las interacciones
que tengo con toda la gente con la que
convivo día con día
y me he dado cuenta de algo que es muy
importante que es que tienes que estar
donde tienes que estar como tienes que
estar cuando tienes que estar
la tercera lección era encontrar los
puntos de conexión más que de los de
distanciamiento es posible si si es
posible
de camino a regreso a casa
y vamos caminando
y me dice mi hijo mamá
aunque no gane cuando corrimos
me la pasé increíble mami si fueras en
mi salón serías mi mejor amiga
y es que en esta vida no importa si
ganas o pierdes la competencia porque
para los ojos de quien verdaderamente
eres importante tú ya eres un ganador
tuya vales la pena en la vida tú ya eres
importante y tú siempre siempre siempre
vas a ser un gran líder solo falta que
ese es el primer paso te pares y te
creas que lo eres porque no hay nadie en
este entero planeta que se parezca a ti
con tus dones con tus talentos con tu
experiencia y con tu brillo y por
pequeño que parezca no te sientas tú hoy
ya has hecho algo que merece muchísimos
aplausos
qué digo aplausos merece una ovación de
pie
porque seguro ya eres el mejor papá la
mejor mamá el mejor hermano el mejor
maestro el mejor colaborador el mejor
hijo el mejor amigo y eres en el mundo
el mejor para algo y para alguien y
estás aquí para algo mucho más
trascendental de lo que te puedas
imaginar
había prendido tres grandes lecciones
ver cosas nuevas y mágicas donde otros
ven siempre lo mismo
levántate siempre y vi no me dolió y
encuentra los puntos de conexión más que
los de distanciamiento es posible si si
es posible y está en tus manos lograrlo
lacoste
ya casi se estaba quedando dormido salgo
de su cuarto lentito y de pronto mami
hoy fuiste la más linda
si mami hoy fuiste la más linda porque
jugaste conmigo a las carreritas
cuando sea grande te voy a invitar a la
luna
yo sigo soñando con ese día en que
vayamos juntos a la luna
lo que sí sé es que todas las noches
cuando veo este reflejo y esta luz me
acuerdo de estas tres grandes lecciones
que me había dado un pequeñito un
pequeñito en un tamaño pero grande muy
grande
en brillo en autenticidad en liderazgo y
en esencia
apuesta alto muy alto hasta la luna
gracias
[Aplausos]